-Progressives in Congress,
including Senate Budget
Chairman Bernie Sanders,
are pushing forward
with the transformative
$3.5 trillion spending plan
that would invest heavily
in climate infrastructure
and historic wildfires,
droughts, and flooding
and, now, centrists with ties
to the fossil fuel industry
are trying to water it down.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
If you've been living pretty
much anywhere in the U.S.,
I don't have to tell you that
the effects of climate change
are here, and they are real.
You can see it everywhere,
from wildfires and droughts
across the West
to intense storms in the Gulf,
to flooding in New York City.
-The Bootleg Fire
in southern Oregon
scorching more
than 280,000 acres.
-Dozens of western wildfires
burning out of control,
sending smoke as far east
as New York City.
-Record-setting
low temperatures.
Lots of areas,
particularly across the South,
not used to serious
winter weather
getting absolutely buried
under snow.
-The remnants of Hurricane Ida
dumped billions
of gallons of water
with stunning speed
on communities
from New York to Maryland.
-The National Weather Service
in New York City,
for the first time
in its history,
issuing a flash flood emergency.
-In Central Park,
5.2 inches of water fell
in just three hours,
a 1-in-500-year rainfall event.
-They're calling it
a once-in-every-500-year
flood here in Philadelphia.
-And, in addition
to the flooding,
people in Pennsylvania
and New Jersey
are also cleaning up
after tornadoes.
-New Jersey tornados.
New Jersey Tornado sounds like
an Arena Football League team.
The New Jersey tornadoes
left a wake of destruction
in their path,
but it could've been
a lot worse,
if they hadn't been stuck
in turnpike traffic.
[ Jersey accent ]
Hey, let's go!
Some of us got trees to uproot.
[ Laughter ]
Don't get in the E-ZPass Lane
if you don't have E-ZPass,
Grandma.
Just for the record,
I would 100%
watch a Jersey-based remake
of the movie "Twister,"
starring Little Steven
and Marisa Tomei.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Little Steven ]
You're not gonna
freakin' believe this,
but a cow just flew by.
[ As Tomei ] You think I didn't
see the freaking cow, you moron?
[Bleep] outta here.
[ Laughter ]
And...
...you knew it was
a New Jersey tornado
because it was
in a velour tracksuit,
shaking down a restaurant owner
for protection money.
[ Jersey accent ]
You don't have my money?
Maybe my friend, here,
blows your pockets inside out.
[ Laughter ]
And those are jokes...
...about New Jersey tornadoes.
Also, the rainfall in New York
was a once-in-a-500-year event.
Think about how crazy that is.
It used to be that
a once-in-a-500-year event
was the F Train arriving on time
or the Jets
starting a season 2 and 0.
[ Laughter ]
It's not an exaggeration to say
that the unprecedented
New York City floods
essentially shut down parts
of the country's largest
transportation system.
I mean, look at this.
-We also have shots
of our subway system here
in New York City
inundated with water,
flooding there.
You can see it.
The entire subway service,
all over the city
of New York City,
suspended because of the
weather from Ida,
which includes, obviously,
rain, flooding.
Look at that.
See at the very back of that?
Look how that water
is just pouring
into the New York City subway.
So the entire New York City
subway system
out of commission right now.
-The flooding was so bad,
they replaced the trains
with kayaks and, even then,
there was a guy
hugging the pole.
[ Laughter ]
Nothing worse than getting
on a kayak at West 4th
and then, you get to 14th
and a mariachi band gets on
and tips the whole thing.
I mean, look at that.
It looks like a Class 5
white water rapid or, I guess,
a brown water rapid?
Anyway, the point is
climate change is causing
all kinds of extreme weather
events across the country.
In the last few months, alone,
New York City has seen
deadly flooding,
record rainfall,
and wildfire smoke drifting
all the way from the West,
that turned the sun red
and made the air unhealthy
to breathe.
And it may seem
counterintuitive,
but scientists are also
investigating
the possibility
that climate change
may have made the record
low temperatures in Texas
that caused power outages
over the winter much worse.
Studies have already found
that Arctic warming
may be driving some winter
extremes in lower latitudes
and pushing cold air
over parts of the U.S.
And The New York Times
reported that...
And I personally think that's
a much more appropriate phrase
because, in addition
to wreaking havoc,
making the planet uninhabitable,
climate change is also
making things much weirder.
Now, it's just normal
for friends to show up to dinner
in late September
looking like they just
ran a marathon.
Pretty soon, the traditional
Thanksgiving feast
is going to be replaced
by a clothing-optional
backyard barbecue.
"It's too hot for turkeys,
so we're just doing
mashed-potato smoothies."
[ Laughter ]
This is how bad
climate change is getting --
wildfires in the West,
floods in the East,
freezing cold in Texas.
Billy Joel's going to have
to write an update for 2021
and call it...
What's that?
[ Laughter ]
You want me to try and do one?
Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Wildfires, power's down ♪
♪ Mare's back in "Easttown" ♪
♪ Bill Gates divorce ♪
♪ Derby's got a doped-up horse ♪
♪ Tracks flooding, toxic air ♪
♪ Biden falling up the stairs ♪
♪ Hurricane, tornadoes ♪
♪ Emmy gold for "Ted Lasso" ♪
[ Laughter ]
What?
You want to do a second verse?!
[ Laughter ]
You think? Okay.
♪ Pfizer versus J&J ♪
♪ Gavin Newsom's A-okay ♪
♪ Nicki's cousin's
friend's sack ♪
♪ Jean Smart's comeback ♪
♪ Brady had a big win ♪
♪ Rudy married his cousin ♪
♪ Rioters at the door ♪
♪ I can't take it anymore ♪
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Say what you will.
That's not a worse song
than the original.
[ Laughter ]
And, on top of floods
and hurricanes
and wildfires
and everything else,
we're also seeing
the devastating effect
on wildlife
and natural ecosystems.
In July,
the New York Times reported
that the Western heat wave
killed marine wildlife
in large numbers...
One marine biologist
told The Times...
And it does.
In fact, I tried to sell
Hollywood Studios
a screenplay for a movie
with that exact plot.
It was called...
It took place
in a dystopian future
where a marine biologist,
played by Brad Pitt,
who's cynical because he thinks
his life is meaningless,
now that all the marine life
has died,
is recruited by a band of rebels
to break the last
remaining dolphin on Earth
out of a government lab
and return him to the ocean.
Just as they escort him
to the edge
of the water to release him,
government agents
assassinate the scientist
and, as he lays there
on the beach,
gasping his last dying breath,
the dolphin says,
"I am sorry you died
for nothing,"
and the scientist said,
"I didn't die for nothing.
I found
my porpoise."
[purpose]
-Well, I liked it.
[ Laughter ]
-Sea Captain?!
What are you doing back on land?
-The ocean is too hot
to sail on, Seth.
[ Laughing ]
Seriously,
somebody do something.
[ Laughter ]
And climate scientists
aren't the only ones using dire
language to warn about the
real-world consequences
we're seeing right now
and how little time we have
to stop climate change
from reaching the tipping point,
where it becomes irreversible.
Yesterday,
President Biden addressed
the United Nations General
Assembly and said this --
-This year has also brought
widespread death and devastation
from the borderless
climate crisis.
The extreme weather events
that we have seen
in every part of the world --
and you all know it
and feel it --
represent what
the secretary-general
has rightly called
Code Red for humanity.
And the scientists and experts
are telling us
that we're fast approaching
a point of no return,
in a literal sense.
-Man, usually,
when you see a guy that age
use dire language like that,
it's because his adult children
keep forgetting
to turn the lights off
when they leave a room.
[ As Biden ]
Come on, guys.
I'm not made of money here.
This is a Code Red.
So the real-world effects
of climate change
are very much here,
as we can see with our own eyes,
and they'll keep getting worse,
unless we do something about it.
The good news is
we can do something about it.
The pair of infrastructure bills
making their way
through Congress right now
would make
significant investments
in climate infrastructure,
including a program
in the reconciliation bill
called the...
As well as strong incentives
to transition
to forms of transportation
that don't depend heavily
on fossil fuels.
-Both of those bills represent
hundreds of billions of dollars
in investments
in renewable energies,
as well as in climate
resiliency efforts
to try and combat
and mitigate, really,
the damage of the effects
of climate change
that we have been seeing
across the country
in recent weeks.
-The president believes
his multitrillion-dollar
infrastructure bill
and spending package
will help the country become
more prepared
for these extreme
weather events.
Some of his climate
provisions include
tax incentives for electric cars
and plans to transition to more
renewable energy sources,
things like wind
and solar power.
-That's great news.
And I won't be sad
to see gas stations go,
but I do think we should keep
the weird little store
where they sell Slim Jims
and air fresheners
and off-brand boner pills.
When you're 13,
a gas station convenience store
is heaven.
It's like a grocery store
where all they sell you
are the stuff you like
and none of the stuff
that's good for you.
And when you get back to the car
and your mom complains
that you bought Funyuns
and Mountain Dews, you can say,
"Oh, I'm sorry.
They were
out of matcha and kale chips
at the Sunoco."
[ Laughter ]
I swear, one time, I stopped
at a gas station in Florida
and there was a section
called...
[ Laughter ]
So the bills currently winding
their way through Congress
would invest in climate
infrastructure and clean energy.
Now, traditionally,
we've been told
that clean energy is, somehow,
more expensive
than fossil fuels,
but a new study provides some
major good news on that front.
It turns out it's the opposite.
-The old way of thinking
about fossil fuels being cheaper
and clean energy meaning lots
of government subsidies
has now been essentially
flipped on its head.
In fact, one recent paper
out of Oxford suggests
that a rapid transition
to green energy
would save trillions of dollars,
based on energy costs, alone.
That's before you even factor in
the benefits
of addressing climate change.
Quoting from the report...
If all the fossil fuel companies
stopped lobbying
against clean power,
if we let the renewable energy
trends continue
at the rate they already
are developing,
we achieve a near-net-zero
emissions energy system
within twenty-five years."
Literally.
According to this report,
if we just sit back,
let things develop
at their current pace,
we will reach near-net-zero
carbon emissions in 25 years.
-That's right -- if we just let
clean energy develop
at the rate
it's currently developing,
without getting in the way,
we could reach
net-zero carbon emissions
in 25 years.
And, personally,
I'm in favor of that
because I'd love
to take the subway
without seeing pigeons
wearing snorkels.
It's huge news.
[ Laughter ]
The transition to clean energy
is actually cheaper
and more cost-effective
than fossil fuels.
We just need it
to happen faster,
before we reach
the tipping point
of irreversible
climate destruction,
which is why we still need
government subsidies
to push it along.
The problem is
that the fossil fuel lobby
is still doing everything it can
to lobby against clean energy
and they have powerful
allies in Washington
doing their bidding,
like West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin,
who chairs
the Senate Energy Committee.
The New York Times
reported that...
And, not only that, Manchin...
I mean, how is it acceptable
that the guy
writing our climate policy
personally profits from coal?
It's like if,
instead of hiding his gambling,
Pete Rose called his bookie
from second base.
[ As Rose ]
Yeah, I want to place a bet
against the Reds.
What am I calling you from?
A cellphone.
Well, it's 1986,
so it's technically possible.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, the writers Googled it.
[ Laughter ]
And then, of course,
there are the lunatics
in the GOP and right-wing media
telling you
Biden's coming to steal your
hamburgers, and outlaw cows.
This is why we need
sustained pressure
to push Congress to implement
the transformative changes
we need to stave off
the worst effects of climate
change before it's too late.
We're already seeing
those effects happen right now,
as Bernie Sanders pointed out
during a Senate speech
last month,
in response to a Republican
senator from Wyoming
fearmongering
about the Green New Deal.
-In case the senator
from Wyoming has missed it,
Oregon is burning.
California is burning.
Greece is burning.
There is a drought
hitting virtually every country
on Earth.
News flash.
Climate change is real!
And the United States
and other countries
have got to address it.
-I love a good use of the word
news flash.
For our younger viewers,
it's what people used to say
before they said,
"Spoiler alert."
I think it comes from,
I don't know,
Chaucer? But...
[ Laughter ]
...it's such an effective
old-man tactic.
I love that Bernie
takes on Republicans
like someone just stole his spot
in the airport parking lot.
"Oh, I'm sorry,
I had a flight to catch."
[ As Sanders ]
Oh, oh, I am sorry,
Your Majesty.
I didn't realize you
had a flight to catch.
Well, news flash.
[ Laughter ]
We all have flights to catch.
You think I'm here
circling the parking lot
because I like buying gum
at the Hudson News?
What's that, honey,
we're out of Trident?
I best rush over to LaGuardia
and replenish our supplies.
[ Laughter ]
Climate change is here.
It's having deadly,
real-world consequences.
We need bold action now
to stave off the worst effects
before it's too late.
We have an opportunity,
right now,
which is why we need sustained
pressure to make it happen.
And I get it --
it's easy to be distracted.
A lot's going on.
As Billy Joel might put it --
♪ Jason's looking good
in teal ♪
-Climate change is real!
-Bernie's got to learn
that cadence.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.